pues vamos a continuar hablando del
mismo tema justamente porque hoy es San
Valentín porque es una fecha que
históricamente nos invita a vivir el
amor romántico pero el amor no tendría
que ser siempre romantizado y Esa visión
podría ser dañina incluso para sostener
relaciones en igualdad y con una
sexualidad sana la vida en pareja
tampoco es imperativa y por eso en este
día de los enamorados queremos
reflexionar sobre las formas de existir
por fuera del amor romántico para ello
me acompaña la doctora Marta Mejía ella
es sexóloga es además
erotóloga de la Universidad de Barcelona
España ese psicóloga de la Universidad
Nacional de Colombia y con maestría en
disfunciones sexuales de la misma
Universidad y además y aquí terminó el
prontuario con 28 años de experiencia
ejerciendo como terapeutas psicosexual
Muchísimas gracias por estar en directo
a América muy buenos días Muchísimas
gracias por la invitación No para nada
El gusto es nuestro y ahora vamos a
empezar hablando de esta necesidad es
realmente necesario el amor romántico o
el amor de pareja y como esas creencias
pueden en determinados casos atajar una
sexualidad sana o extraordinaria
pregunta porque verás es un ideal es un
ideal que va apareado de ese deseo esa
expectativa que a su vez ataña y vincula
con varios aspectos muy importantes que
los psicólogos Tratamos de encajar como
en los cuatro principales uno es el de
la vinculación
afectivo sexual dos es esa idealización
de pareja de para querer compartir el
resto de mi vida con esa persona o sea
montamos nuestro proyecto de vida allí
tres Pues todo lo relacionado a la
interrelación
sueños proyectos y tres nosotros los
sexólogos la consideramos muy importante
que es el Deseo ver su sexualidad
Entonces es una idealización en general
que con el paso del tiempo Enhorabuena
ha venido
modificándose sí se ha salido un poco de
tiempos cuando nuestros padres estaban
tanto más atañeada a situaciones muy
vinculadas a roles puntuales hoy día
pues ya nos hemos venido un poco
abriendo Más sin embargo sigue
prevaleciendo De cualquier manera en lo
que nos inculcan en la infanto
adolescencia con esas pautas y esas
creencias que nos educan Pues
nos cuesta porque es que prácticamente
vienen en nuestras improntas vienen con
nosotros y nos cuesta a la sociedad de
alguna manera la refuerza el estilo de
vida el entorno pero Enhorabuena cada
vez más y nuestras nuevas generaciones
Pues están un poco más acudiéndose
expandiéndose y como un poco teniendo
más claridad esta autonomía que Debería
ser en general con nuestro periodista de
salud hablábamos hace unos minutos que
estas condiciones o estas improntas van
a depender mucho de nuestros orígenes de
nuestro nivel educativo de la forma en
que hemos sido creados en casa sin
embargo Sí hay patrones muy
diferenciados entre la crianza de las
mujeres y la crianza de los hombres en
cuanto a lo que se refiere a la
sexualidad y a las relaciones
interpersonales porque han sido tan
importantes estas diferencias para
generar por ejemplo brechas de
discriminación entre nosotros y y cómo
cerramos esos puntos que nos separan y
que no nos permiten vivir a plenitud en
nuestra sexualidad y nuestra vida o si
es verdad digamos que todavía el yugo de
los roles está muy exacerbado
definitivamente pero profesionales en el
área de la salud cada vez somos mucho
más recalcitrantes en el tema por
ejemplo cuando el consultante te dice
Bueno yo estoy apoyando a mi pareja en
las labores domésticas en ese caso da
lugar muy bien pero El caso es una
responsabilidad también te corresponde
tal cual también te corres es una
responsabilidad Entonces es empezar a
educar el léxico porque nosotras
básicamente lo damos por hecho como si
nos están ayudando nos están apoyando
Qué bueno es mi marido que bueno es mi
mi compañero además al contrario
empecemos por nosotras por conocernos y
entre más nos conozcamos y más claras
tengamos nuestro nuestro nuestros sueños
proyectos nuestro estilo de vida
nuestras preferencias que queremos que
deseamos A qué le apuntamos en la vida
pues en ese mismo sentido pues vamos a
tener una demanda
Autónoma al respecto Entonces es mucho
la reeducación desde el léxico y desde
que nosotras estemos abiertas también
estemos abiertas a aceptarla porque es
que a veces e incluso yo recibo
pacientes donde dice no eso me
corresponde a mí entonces no Mira
educación educación es una
descodificación ahora hablando
específicamente del caso de las mujeres
también hay un tema del empoderamiento
no que quiero yo en la sexualidad que me
gusta de mi relación de proximidad con
mi o mis parejas y Cómo consigo ese
relacionamiento con las otras personas
No
acá me gustaría profundizar un poquito
más en la facultad que me da de ser
psicólogo y sexóloga que también el tema
de la educación es que no tenemos mucha
Claridad en la sexualidad e incluso casi
siempre atañamos la sexualidad la
genitalidad y sexualidad Es todo es
Quiénes Somos la forma de comportarnos
de pensar de relacionarnos en general
esa sexualidad genitalidad ya es lo que
ataña netamente a los genitales verse
entonces una sexualidad como tal es la
autonomía es la espontaneidad es la
fluidez de la persona y es la
interrelación del ser humano como tal la
pasión y el erotismo ya son cosas más
más privadas son cosas más eróticas
entonces empecemos por tener claridad
que la sexualidad es muy diferente al
erotismo a la pasión y a la genitalidad
y esto nos ayuda a tener una libertad
más amplia de cómo relacionarnos primero
conocernos y luego como relacionarnos
con el entorno y con la pareja en ese
entorno en ese aspecto como tal Y eso
sin pensar en estas dismorfias que se
crean en nosotros por un amor que ha
sido
heteronormativo y que ha sido binario
por mucho tiempo cosa que está cayendo
por suerte y aquí le quiero hacer mi
última pregunta el amor romántico se
ajusta a los cuerpos diversos
así en la medida que estemos todos en la
disponibilidad en la disposición y en la
apertura precisamente de esa fluidez
justamente de ahí que es un constructo
Pero lo podemos llevar a Elevar de
acuerdo a la necesidad a la expectativa
a la sensación que cada uno
considere pero sobre todo que desde
conocernos desde la cultura y desde
nuestras preferencias optemos porque
vivamos en esa libertad vivamos en esa
armonía y también
su giramos ese aspecto del respeto no
del respeto al compañero y al entorno en
general un amor que es saludable siempre
y cuando no sea siempre binario y sea
siempre respetuoso gracias a usted con
todo gusto Muchas gracias